- RICK NICKLESBY REPORTING LIVE
FROM A GRUESOME SCENE.
A CULT KNOWN AS Q.E.T.,
OR QUEST FOR ETERNAL TRUTH,
HAS APPARENTLY TAKEN THEIR
OWN LIVES IN A MASS SUICIDE.
POLICE CONFIRM THAT
CYANIDE-LACED CHERRY KOOL-AID
WAS ALSO ON THE PREMISES.
EXCUSE ME. HI.
RICK NICKLESBY, CHANNEL 6.
HI. ARE YOU TWO
FROM THE NEIGHBORHOOD?
- YES.
- NO.
[both speaking gibberish]
- OKAY, WERE YOU TWO MEMBERS
OF THE CULT THAT LIVED HERE?
- THE CUL--WHAT CULT?
- WHAT?
- WAS THIS A CULT RIGHT HERE?
- CULT?
- I HAD NO IDEA THIS WAS A CULT.
- NO WAY.
- A CULT?
- ALTHOUGH I WILL SAY,
THE TERM "CULT"
IS A LITTLE JUDGMENTAL.
- I WOULD SAY
THE SAME THING, YEAH.
- NOT KNOWING THE FULL DOCTRINE.
- MM-HMM, MM-HMM.
- WELL, APPARENTLY,
THEY BELIEVED THAT THERE WAS
A SPACESHIP WAITING FOR THEM
BEHIND THE MOON.
- OKAY, WELL, YOU KNOW,
THAT STILL IS REALLY POSSIBLE.
- NOT COMPLETELY CRAZY.
- IT'S POSSIBLE, RIGHT?
I MEAN, WHO KNOWS WHAT IS
OUT THERE IN THE UNIVERSE?
- ANYTHING COULD BE
BEHIND THE MOON.
- OKAY, WELL, IT APPEARS
THEY KILLED THEMSELVES
IN ORDER TO BOARD THE SHIP.
- RIGHT, AND THAT'S WHERE
WE DISAGREED WITH THEM,
RIGHT THERE,
OR WOULD HAVE--
WE WOULD HAVE DISAGREED
WITH THEM
HAD WE BEEN THERE
ON OUR DEPARTURE DAY--
THEIR DEPARTURE DAY.
THEIR DEPARTURE DAY!
- YEAH.
- WHICH IS THE DAY
THAT THEY DID THIS.
I MEAN, THAT'S WHAT YOU
COULD CALL IT,
IF YOU WANTED TO--
I AIN'T IN NO CULT.
- NO, I MEAN, WHAT I ALWAYS
WONDERED IS HOW--
OR AM STARTING TO WONDER,
SINCE YOU BROUGHT THIS
TO OUR ATTENTION--
WHY--IF THERE WAS A SPACESHIP
IN THE SKY,
WHY WOULDN'T IT JUST
BEAM US UP--BEAM THEM UP?
- RIGHT, JUST BEAM 'EM--
JUST BEAM THEM UP.
WHY CAN'T YOU JUST
BEAM THEM UP ALIVE?
WHY YOU GOT TO BE DEAD
TO GET BEAMED UP?
YOU KNOW WHAT I'M SAYING?
I'VE BEEN SAYING THAT
FOR WEEKS--SECONDS.
FOR SECONDS, 'CAUSE--
BECAUSE YOU, RICK NICKLESBY,
YOU TOLD US THAT,
YOU KNOW,
AND THAT'S HOW I KNEW,
BECAUSE--
- 15 SECONDS AGO.
- 15 SECONDS AGO, YOU SAID IT.
I DIDN'T KNOW ANYTHING ABOUT IT
UNTIL YOU SAID IT,
'CAUSE I AIN'T IN NO CULT.
- OKAY, THEN WHY WOULD SOMEONE
JOIN A CULT?
- COMPELLING LEADERSHIP.
- CHARISMATIC LEADER.
- [stammering]
LIKE, A COMPELLING--
- TACO TUESDAYS.
- A PERSON--
- I MEAN, HYPOTHETICALLY,
THEY COULD HAVE HAD TACOS
ON TUESDAY,
WHICH WOULD HAVE BEEN A DRAW.
I MEAN, THAT WOULD HAVE BEEN
A PLUS.
- OKAY, SO THIS IS
A TRAGIC DAY
FOR THIS COMMUNITY
AND FOR THE MEMBERS
OF THE QUEST FOR EARTHLY TRUTH.
I'M RICK NICKLESBY REPORTING--
WHOA.
- YOU SEE?
- YEP.
- UH-HUH.
EVERYBODY JUMPED THE GUN.
- [gasping]
- WE'RE READY!
- [laughing]